we turn now to the fbi search of
mar-a-lago former president donald trump
overnight calling for the immediate
release of the search affidavit while
the department of justice has asked a
judge to keep that affidavit in the case
sealed catherine herridge is outside the
doj for us this morning catherine good
morning
good morning tony while a federal judge
has the final say in new court filings
the justice department says revealing
the underlying evidence for the search
warrant could jeopardize their ongoing
case according to court filings late
monday prosecutors said unsealing the
law enforcement affidavit would cause
significant and irreparable damage serve
as a road map to the government's
ongoing investigation and chill future
cooperation by witnesses several media
outlets including cbs news petitioned
the court to unseal the document that
convinced a federal judge to authorize
the search at mar-a-lago last monday
after that search and subsequent
political controversy federal
authorities warned of increased threats
to law enforcement and on monday a
pennsylvania man adam bees was in court
accused in a federal complaint of making
multiple threats online against law
enforcement after the florida search
among them if you work for the fbi then
you deserve to die
former president trump told fox news
monday that he has reached out to the
doj to offer his help amid the growing
threats against law enforcement saying
the temperature has to be brought down
while live the online chatter is general
the intelligence memo says there are
specific evidence about proposed targets
including addresses weapons and tactics
nate
catherine thank you